وصف رئيس الاتحاد الدولي لكره القدم جياني
انفنتينو
الانتقادات المتعلقه بكاس العالم بالدروس
الاخلاقيه التي تنم عن النفاق و خلال
مؤتمر صحفي في الدوحه قال ان الاوروبيين
عليهما الاعتذار عن ما فعلوه في العالم
خلال عقود ماضيه قبل اعطاء دروس في
الاخلاق
يه من الاوروبيين ومن دول غربيه انا مواطن
اوروبي واعتقد ما قمنا به اوروبيين على
مدار 3000 سنه يتعين علينا الاعتذار عنه
على مدار ثلاثه الاف سنه المقبله قبل ان
نعطي دروسا للاخرين هذه الدروس الاخلاق
هل تحدثت اي منها عن حقوق العمال هل حقا
يقترثون لظروف العمال لا احد لكن الفيفا
وليكون منصفا قطر
هم يمكنهم الدفاع عن انفسهم انا هنا كي
يدافعا كره القدم والعداله
واضافنتينو رئيس الاتحاد الدولي لكره
القدم ان الظروف العمال في اوروبا ليست
الافضل
الى اوروبا وصلوا في ظروف صعبه بعضهم توفي
في التاريخ لا نسمح لاي عامل من هذه الدول
الاسيويه اي يعمل بطريقه شرعيه ونعلم كم
هو عدد العمال غير الشرايين في دولنا
الاوروبيه وظروفهم التي هي ليست الافضل
واكد رئيس الاتحاد الدولي لكره القدم
جياني انفانتينو جاهزيه دوله قطر التامه
لاستضافه افضل كاس للعالم وكذلك استعداد
القائمين على البطوله لتوفير اجواء امنه
للجماهير
الدوحه جاهزه قطر جاهزه ستكون افضل بطوله
جميع القائمين على البطوله مستعدون لخدمه
ضيوف المونديال وتوفير اجواء امنه لهم في
كافه المناحي من الاقامه والمعيشه والطعام
وقال انفنتينو ان قطر تطورت كثيرا في مجال
حمايه حقوق العمال وانه كان على اطلاع
بالتطور الذي حققته قطر في مجال حقوق
الانسان
الماضيه يجعلني استحضر قصه الشخصيه انا
ابن عائله من العمال والدي كان يعملان في
ظروف صعبه للغايه ليس في قطر ولكن في
سويسرا اتذكر جيدا ولا اتحدث عن نظام
عنصري بل اتحدث عن سويسرا حيث عاش اجدادي
وعامله هناك
وما الحقوق التي كانوا يحصلون عليها وما
الحقوق التي حرم منها اتذكر عندما كنت
طفلا كيف كان العمال المهاجرون يتم
التعامل معهم عندما يعبرون الحدود بحث عن
عمل وماذا كان يحدث بجوازاتهم وفحوصاتهم
الطبيه وعندما اتيت للدوحه اول مره بعد
انتخاب لرئاسه الفيفا اردت رؤيه احدها
هؤلاء العمال واماكن سكنهم واسترجعت حينها
طفولتي وقلت للمسؤولين في قطر يجب تحسين
ظروف العمال قطر تطورت كثيره في مجال ايه
حقوق العمال وكنت على اطلاع على ذلك